Hello Freak bitches.
But then to find out it's an actual movie with Jodie foster.
It's like,
what did,
how did get reviews,
how did Jody foster gets sucked into this fucking movie?
Like she looks great by the way.
50 years old this year at the Oscars or whatever.
Wow.
Two fingers and he looks phenomenal.
Her tight like
damn.
She's hunting some shots.
I am.
I know.
Pow Wow.
Is that the noise that she makes when she has a Jodie Foster's having sex?
Jody having sex chicks are just coming over and eat her now.
Come on over.
I come get something poached egg and come on,
get some,
I'll be a fly on the wall.
Yeah.
She um,
I dunno.
She have a baby or anything or boyfriend,
girlfriend,
married or any of those things.
She is she out of the closet now?
So she speaks fluent.
Isn't it funny that that's like a big issue?
Like whether a check is a lesbian?
Yeah.
I don't give a fuck.
You can tell just by the way she talks or something where its smell.
But the thing is a woman like here's the issue.
Here's the legitimate shoe for real.
A woman like Jodie foster can come out of the closet and still play someone's
wife,
no problem.
And no one has a problem with it.
If Tom Cruise,
and I'm not saying Tom Cruise's gay,
but if Tom Cruise was gay and he came out of the closet and um,
then wanted to do a movie where he was making out with the chairs over,
it's over.
That's,
that's reality.
I mean that I believe,
I mean,
I shouldn't say it's reality because I'm basing it on my own personal feelings
of how it would know they would go down.
It might go down differently,
but I think that,
you know,
the,
the people that do polling for politicians and stuff like that,
I mean,
you'd be amazed at how irrational voters are.
How,
how,
how finding out one little thing about somebody's past can really sway an
election.
So people are very,
you know,
for the most part,
people are pretty conservative in their ideologies.
It doesn't seem to be an issue when you're women that are coming out.
It's like we don't really have that much of a problem with that.
There's no like there's not a trace trace and I really think it's a high,
you're bumping muffs and you're making out neediness to cock
needing,
so there's also that stigma of disease and all that,
so that comes with it too,
right?
With the gay side.
What if they're just in a jerking off each other?
Completely different.
I never got clean.
Those clubs are staring each other in the head.
They're looking at,
well,
look it away.
What are you worried about over here for a second as a Goof,
I'm going to jerk it off.
I've been shaving around my dick because they say it makes my dick look bigger,
but I'm not convinced.
Can you give me an opinion?
Wants you to be objective here?
Let me give it a look.
I'd give it a look.
I don't think it looks any big.
That looks a lot bigger.
I'm telling Ya,
it doesn't look good.
I be honest with you,
it doesn't even live there.
You can choke you with this.
You look like you should have a hold of this right now.
I'm just suck it.
And it wouldn't even feel bad.
It would just go all the way in your mouth.
I mean,
I'm betting.
What did he try to right now?
Bet going mouth.
You mean you don't think you could feel it?
We need to try.
You need to do another Mikey and Tony in the basement.
This was the character's names.
Do Remember?
Um,
Mikey.
One of them was Mikey and then it was the mom who is Kelly.
Kirsten.
Yeah.
She was great.
[inaudible]
yeah.